The situation with Paul's Church in Corinth is very different from the situation
we saw in first Thessalonians.
First Thessalonians shows us a church that is new in its infancy,
is just been founded.
First Corinthians shows us a church of,
and it's sort of adolescent period.
They've had some growing pains and they've got some problems,
but you can tell that they're not all brand new Christians.
Look at first Corinthians 15.
Take your bibles out.
Remember,
you have to follow along.
First Corinthians 15,
this is when Paul is addressing the issue of the resurrection of the body.
Uh,
so early Christian groups wrestled with the kind of question,
uh,
that people sometimes still do,
which is what happens to you and you're dead.
Are you dead like rover in dead all over our,
does your soul go off to some of the place art as some part of you get
reincarnated into somebody else's body or in the Orthodox Christian,
uh,
confessions,
you confessed the resurrection of the body at the end of time,
at the end of this worldly time.
So Christians,
we're dealing with this stuff.
Paul has to address this question in First Corinthians 15 because there's some
confusion or some debate in the church there.
So read along with me.
First Corinthians 15 verse 20 we're going to skip around a bit,
but I'm going to cover a lot of,
uh,
cover a lot of ground in this lecture.
So you need to really follow along in the text as best you can so you don't get
too confused was where I am first going.
Use 15 verse 20,
in fact.
But in fact,
Christ has been raised from the dead.
The first fruits of those who have died for since death came through a human
being.
The resurrection of the dead has also come through a human being for all,
for as all die in Adam.
So all will be made alive in Christ,
but each in his own order,
Christ the first fruits than it is coming.
Those who belong to Christ then comes the end.
When he hands over the kingdom to God,
the father,
after he has destroyed every ruler and every authority and every power.
So notice the resurrection of Jesus.
For Paul,
this is gonna be very important.
The resurrection of Jesus for Paul is not different in kind from the
resurrection that Christians can expect.
So the resurrection of Christians bodies will be just like the resurrection of
Jesus,
his body in kind.
That's important because a whole lot of people think that what Jesus experienced
in some kind of rent what they,
what early critically about Jews was something very different from what uh,
they confess about Christians.
But for Paul,
they're the same kind of resurrection.
That's why just because Christ's resurrection,
the first fruits,
it's just the first apple on the tree.
It just lets you know that harvest time is now here,
but it's just the first apple.
You'll have lots of other apples.
So that's the first.
Christ's resurrection is the first fruits and then he'll do it.
Have there been time he,
there's a big war type thing and then Christ defeats all the rulers and the
authorities and powers on the earth and hands over the kingdom.
Verse 25 for he must reign until he has put all his enemies under his feet for
the last enemy to be destroyed is death.
Oh,
okay.
That's good enough for that point.
But now skip down to verse 35 see what happens is that some people in in Corinth
are,
are questioning this now,
what are they question?
Are they saying that people don't live forever at all or that there is no
afterlife experience?
It looks like not,
it looks like what they're really questioning is simply the resurrection of the
body idea.
Because of course they're saying they might be thinking like a lot of people in
the ancient world,
there were other,
lots of Jews believed in the resurrection of the body.
And so it was uh,
an idea that was not unknown to people but think they,
they people in the ancient world also objective by saying,
yeah,
but how is that possible?
I mean,
the bar,
we all know the body rots when you put it in the ground.
It just decomposes and it just comes all a little molecules of other things and
how to,
and then that is,
you know,
it grows into trees and other grass,
the molecules,
my dead body become recycled in the universe.
The ancient people knew this.
They would even say,
what about sailors who are lost at sea and fish eat their bodies and then other
fish eat those bodies of those fish and then other fish eat those bodies of
those fish.
And then maybe one of those fish gets caught and you eat that body you met,
you had sort of little pieces of Fred,
the sailor,
you know in your body.
How,
how's God going to pull all that stuff together and resurrect that body?
So this was a debate that people in ancient Rome had to,
apparently some of the people in Corinth,
they're having the same kind of idea.
How is this possible?
So Paul addresses that.
Someone will ask,
how are the dead raised with what kind of body do they come fool?
Okay,
since what says,
I started following along,
fool,
what you saw does not come to life unless it dies.
And that's for what you sow.
You do not sow the body that is to be,
but a bare seed perhaps of wheat or of some other grain,
but God gives it a body as he is chosen and to each kind of seed it's own body.
Just like a seed goes into the ground,
what comes up as a flower or a plant doesn't look like the seed.
It's not even necessarily all the same.
Complete stuff is new stuff,
but it's still continuous with it.
Not all flushes or like there was one flesh for human beings,
another for animals,
another for birds and another for fish and notice that's in kind of a hierarchy
there of beings,
animals or humans or are higher than animals.
Animals are higher than birds.
Birds are higher than fish.
On this kind of ontological scale of different kinds of bodies that Paul is
working with him here.
This is a common assumption in the ancient world also,
there are heavenly bodies and earthly bodies.
What our earthly bodies,
hours,
this dogs,
cats,
everything that everything's a body that's that physical for these people.
What are the earth?
What are the heavenly bodies,
the sun,
the moon,
and the stars.
They,
all these things are themselves in ancient ideas.
Bodies that simply actually are fixed into kind of a dome.
That's the sky and they travel around on that dome.
So the earth,
the this,
all these things in the in the sky are also bodies.
The glory of the heavenly is one thing that of the earth he has another.
There is one glory for the sun,
another glory for the Moon,
another glory for the stars.
Indeed star differs from star in glory.
Again,
a hierarchy of different kinds of bodies,
so it is with the resurrection of the dead.
What is sown is perishable.
What is raised is imperishable.
It is sown in dishonor.
It is raised in glory.
It is sown in weakness.
It is raised in power.
It is sown.
Now here you get into a translation problem.
My translations here says in verse 44 it is sown a physical body.
It is raised a spiritual body.
Does anybody translation have something different at that verse
is sown a natural body and it is raised in a spiritual body?
Is that what it says?
It's anybody else have a different translation for those,
the problem is the word translated physical here is not really the Greek word
physical.
There is a Greek word physical.
What's trendy?
What's what they're talking about here is what is sown is a psychic,
a body made of soup coasts.
The Greek word for soul.
What stone is a soul ish body is what he's talking about.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a heavy,
it's a denser kind of body and what is raised is a spiritual body,
but whereas in the modern world,
we tend to think spiritual is something that's in material.
Spiritual means not matter.
It's invisible.
It's something that doesn't exist as matter.
That's not what [inaudible] means in the ancient world.
In the ancient world,
Kanuma is like is a stuff,
it's like what Arabs made it of when the wind blows around,
that's punch Luma
going on.
When you take in breath,
you're taking in a form of Panola.
That Greek word Sonoma does refer in the ancient world to some kind of stuff.
It doesn't refer to in material substance as it does later in Christian theology
or in some philosophies.
So what Paul,
the translation here is misleading because what Paula says is when your body is
put into the ground,
when you're dead,
what's put in there is sort of a psychic body.
It's a body that carries life.
Sure.
Cause that's what psychic means for in the ancient Greek word is it's a lot.
It's a living body,
but it is more like something that,
it's a natural but he's kind of the body that you're just given with naturally.
But what is raised is going to be ready to say a pneumatic body,
but now a pneumatic body.
So it's not the same thing as it was put in the ground.
It's raised a pneumatic body,
but it's still some kind of stuff.
If there is a physical body there I was also a spiritual body,
a pneumatic body.
Thus it is written.
The first man Adam became a living being the last Adam became a life giving
Kanuma but it is not the [inaudible] that is first.
But the psychic and then the Kanuma.
The first man was from the earth,
a man of dust.
The second man is from heaven.
Notice that he talked about heavenly bodies earlier and he says the resurrected
body is going to be a heavenly body.
Also,
this indicates that in the end a lot of ancient thought,
they thought that the sun and the moon and the stars were themselves pneumatic
bodies.
They were bodies made of this stuff of Numa
as was the man of dust or are those from the dust as of the man of heaven.
So are those from heaven.
Just as we have borne the image of the man of dust,
we will also bear the image of the man of heaven.
What I'm saying,
brothers is this flesh and blood cannot inherit the Kingdom of God,
nor does the perishable inherit the imperishable flesh and blood cannot inherit
the Kingdom of God.
Notice what he's saying is that the resurrected body that he is expecting is not
a flesh and blood body.
So when Paul is thinking about however the resurrection of Christ happened,
he doesn't imagine it as the very same flesh and bud.
It's not like it is in the movies where the various same flesh and blood of the
dead,
Jesus' body somehow resuscitates and walks out of the tomb.
That's how people popularly imagined it.
That must not have.
And that's how it clearly some already early Christians thought of it.
You can.
Some early Christians thought precisely that it was the,
the flesh and blood body of Jesus that got up and walked out of the tomb.
Paul must not have thought that because he says the body that we will as
Christians,
as followers of Christ have when we are resurrected is a pneumatic body,
not a flesh and blood body.
It's still a physical body.
And Paul since cause he believes it per numa is matter.
So what would be raised is this pneumatic body.
Now the reason why,
so why is Paul getting into all this?
For one thing,
it shows,
like I said,
this is a church that's not totally infant church,
but it's also an adolescent church.
These are people who have some much more exposure to Paul's teaching and to the
Gospel and different Christian ideas.
Then say the Thessaloniki and Christians did.
But they're still very confused about a lot of things that Paul seems to be
quite certain about.
So apparently some of these people in this church,
they had heard this teaching about the resurrection of the body.
So apparently they've heard this already.
They're not like the Thessaloniki and who just don't seem to know that
anything's going to happen to their brothers and sisters after their death.
So they're comp policy saying,
no,
no.
The dead in Christ will rise.
We'll go meet Jesus in the air.
That'd be a big party.
And if they're dead now,
they won't miss out on the party.
The Corinthians don't have that problem.
They know there's some kind of afterlife preaching and teaching,
but some of them seem to be rejecting the most obvious crude way of
understanding the resurrection,
the body as if the very flesh and blood will somehow resuscitate and come back
to life.
And so Paul says,
no,
no.
That's not how it happens.
It's more complicated than that.
There's a spiritual body and then there's this natural body in the spiritual
body is the one that's going to be raised.
Now it's perfectly natural though for people to have raised these objections
precisely because if they heard Paul's preaching about the resurrection of the
body,
they precisely would think,
well not how,
how would that happen?
And that would be skeptical of it.
Especially if they had any kind of sort of more philosophical education.
They would think,
ah,
yeah,
that's superstition.
The idea that bodies,
you know,
can,
zombies can kind of get up out of the grave and walk around.
That's just superstition.
Simple people might believe that,
but we're more educated.
We don't believe that kind of stuff.
So this shows that this church is in a bit different situation.
There's going to be some cosmic transformation that will happen at the end of
time.
This is not an individual thing either.
It's not like every individual person sort of,
uh,
experiences your afterlife,
your experience in your,
your resurrection all at a different time.
It's,
it's all the same time,
uh,
policies.
Imagine that,
uh,
people will sleep in the ground and then at the end of time the Messiah will
come back and as big resurrection of,
of pneumatic bodies will occur.
So notice though that this is the issue he read.
He relates in just first Corinthians 15,
and we're going to back up then and talk about how does that issue about the
resurrection from the body relate to other parts of the letter and had it,
what does that tell us about this church?
But first a little background on what this is.
Corinth is a very important city in the ancient Greek world.
It's right on the isthmus of Corinth.
That little narrow strip of land that connects the main part of Greece where
Athens is a Kia to the southern part of Greece called the Peloponnese for the
Peloponnesus.
Uh,
and so it was an important,
uh,
through way,
both by land because every,
all trade and travel that went from northern Greece to southern Greece or vice
versa had to go right through Corinth.
So it was a very important for trade.
It was also though where,
um,
they didn't have a canal there now so that you can,
don't have to sail around the southern part of Greece.
You can just go through the canal.
But back then they didn't have a canal.
So they had these big tracks and so ships would come up and can crank out one
part on one side,
uh,
of the,
of Greece.
And they would unload all their stuff,
put them on the big tracks,
and they would take it across the isthmus and then load it back on other ships.
So this is a hugely important,
uh,
city.
As far as trade went,
it was also important for Rome.
Rome had destroyed Corinth previously in the one forties BCE because Corinth was
helping to lead rebellions against the Rollins who are increasing their power in
the eastern part of the Mediterranean.
So Rome,
the Romans destroyed Corinth.
And then let,
let that way for about a hundred years.
It had been refounded again in the forties.
Um,
and then settled with ramen veterans.
So by the time that Paul writes this letter and the say the middle of the first
century Ce,
our era,
uh,
roam,
Corinth is still a very romanized kind of place.
So it's got a blend of Greek cultures and a blend of Roman cultures.
In fact,
the inscriptions in Corinth up until the years one 30 or so,
we're still predominantly in Latin in Corinth,
which was very unusual in the ancient world,
but it shows that,
uh,
the Romans and Latin was a very,
it was very important.
So Corinth was a Roman colony,
which made it both a Greek place and a romanized place.
Found Paul founded the church there himself.
Uh,
it talks it in acts 18 one through 18.
and in this case,
we don't have a whole lot of way to,
to dispute a lot of what acts tells us about Corinth,
although,
uh,
we can't take it as straight forward historically either.
Paul writes his letter to the Corinthians,
first Corinthians from Ephesus,
as he says in Chapter 16.
And Paul has gotten his information about what's going on at the church in
Corinth from several different sources.
For one thing,
and we're going to flip around a bit,
look at First Corinthians one 11 chapter one,
verse 11,
uh,
Four.
It has been reported to me by Chloe's people that there are quarrels among you.
Some people say,
I belong to Paul.
I belonged to Apollo's,
I belonged to cvs or I belong to Christ.
Chloe's people.
What does that mean?
We'll close obviously a woman's name.
And when you say,
when you hear this in Greek,
somebody,
people those,
they're good guys.
We those around Chloe.
This refers to probably members of her own household.
They could be slaves,
that could be her freed persons,
that could be clients.
It probably refers two clients are slaves are Friedman of Chloe herself.
So say they're members of this church.
Now it doesn't tell us that Chloe herself is a member of the church.
She might be because Paul names her out by name,
but we don't know that for sure.
But at least some of the members of her household are,
and they have gone to Paul and told him stuff that's going on.
So he gets some of his information from close people.
And like I said,
those may well be slaves.
Are freed persons,
was that important?
Well,
at least it means they're probably not members of the,
you know,
upper class or,
or high high status members.
But he also gets information from a letter.
So in in chapter seven verse one he says now concerning the things he wrote
concerning the matters about which you wrote,
and then he says it is well for a man not to touch a woman.
So then he gets into the issues of sexuality,
marriage,
divorce and those kinds of things.
So he's also though received a letter that from at least other people in Corinth
that raises different issues.
Well what do we do about divorce?
What did it about marriage,
what to do about sex?
And then it ray.
And so from chapter seven on he raises different issues that may have been
raised in their letter to him.
So that's one place he gets information.
He also mentions in 16 2012 that Apollos has,
has come in is with him in emphasis now in policies come from corn.
So he probably get some information from Apollo's who is not who Paul talks
about,
a policy as a coworker,
not as his sort of servant or his assistant or anything like that.
In fact,
when Paul talks about Timothy,
it's clear that Timothy is Paul's assistant because Paul says,
I sent Timothy Someplace.
But when he talks about a policy,
says I've urged Apollos to go to come,
come visit you.
In other words,
Paul,
Paul doesn't say he sent a polos anywhere.
There's indicates that Apollos is on something more of an equal status with
Paul.
Maybe policy is considered another apostle or a teacher or something like that
in early church,
but it,
Paul May have gotten some of the information there.
And then in chapter 16,
17,
he talks about,
uh,
I rejoiced at the coming of Stephanus and Fortune Addis and a caucus because
they have made up for your absence.
Now there are a couple of interesting things about these names.
A Kaia cause would mean would be sort of a name or a nickname for someone who's
from a k up the area just north of Corinth.
Uh,
where,
uh,
that means that area of Greece,
Stephanie,
this is a very Greek word,
meaning a crown.
And Fortunate Naddis though is not a Greek word.
It's from the Latin,
right?
So F and fortune,
not us.
Does and means fortune.
Someone who's fortunate or lucky.
It's like having a,
you know,
a person named lucky.
So does this mean that this guy was a himself Roman or maybe was a freed person
of a Roman and therefore had a Latinized name,
whatever.
We don't know about that,
but he's,
Paul apparently had gotten information from them also and it talks about a
church in their house.
So there are they,
what's going on in corn is there seem to be different house churches in Corinth
is not all one group meeting all the time in one place.
So we could imagine different house churches meeting in different places and
maybe made up of different kinds of people.
And one of the ways we're going to talk about this is to see what was the social
class of these people in First Corinthians one 26 we get our first major clue.
Consider your own call.
Brothers and sisters,
not many of you.
And again the Greek doesn't have sisters.
They've added that to the English to make it more inclusive.
Not many of you were wise by human standards.
Not many were powerful,
not many were of noble birth.
Now they'll all three of those words in the Greek,
our status symbol words.
Why is it doesn't mean just smart.
It means educated.
So not many of you are well educated.
Not many of you are powerful.
That is you're not going to keep people occupying government positions or
anything like that and you're not of noble birth,
but God chose what is foolish in the world to shame the wise God chose what is
weak in the world to shame the strong God chose what is low and despised in the
world.
Things that are not to reduce to nothing.
Things that are now at one point that those verses were taken to indicate that
all of the Corinthian church,
we're very,
we're just completely low class,
that they were all either slaves are poor,
Freedman are lower class manual laborers and this kind of went along with the
image that a lot of you saw a lot about Christianity and popular movies like Ben
Hur or the robe or things like this,
which has the earliest Christians,
all kinds of hiding away from the Romans in little dark rooms and all being very
much laboring class people.
More recently scholars who said,
yeah,
but that's not exactly what Paul says.
He says not many of you wear these things,
which at least implies that some people in the Corinthian church actually were
wise,
maybe educated,
uh,
of noble birth or having some kind of access to power.
So this is one clue,
this stuck.
There's car scholars in the last 30 40 years to reread the Corinthian
correspondence,
both first Corinthians and second Corinthians precisely by take,
looking at what's going on with regard to social status and social class.
And now it gets really interesting because the typical way to read the Bible
that most of us grew up with is you read it very piously.
You read it as having something to say about theology.
You read it and having some say about God and all those are obviously important
ways to read the Bible.
But it's also when you add into issues like Mike,
this text not only had something to say about theology but also about issues
like social class and power.
And scholars have said it's precisely in First Corinthians.
That's one of the places we see in the New Testament.
The best evidence we have,
that the early churches weren't all homogeneous when it comes to their social
status level.
And they may have actually experienced conflicts in their groups do precisely to
differences in social status and social power.
So that's the way I have interpreted first Corinthians.
And uh,
it's,
it's debated by some people,
but it's much more the consensus view now among scholars that especially
Corinthian,
the Corinthian correspondence does have these evidence of class levels.
So let's see,
how is this working out?
I just read the first passage where Paul seems to say some of you are claiming
I'm bi,
I'm for Paul,
I'm going to Paul's people.
I want to apologize people.
I'm one of CIF US as people.
And of course cfs is just the Aramaic name for Peter.
Exactly.
Uh,
Peters,
the Greek name.
See if this is the air air McNain name for the rock.
And so spending,
and in some people in the church is saying,
I'm one of Christ's man.
So these parties that seem to have been developed,
or at least there's some kind of glomming on to different leaders.
And some people have said these maybe episode represent actually for different
specific delineate parties in corn.
I tend to doubt that because I don't think you see any evidence the rest of the
way in the correspondence that there are four distinct groups.
I do think there are basically two groups that are going on in opposition to one
another in court.
And that's what I build my uh,
reconstruction on.
So people are having their favorite,
uh,
apostles.
What are some of the other,
the resurrection of the body is one thing,
but there are several other issues.
And now that you've all read first Corinthians so carefully,
uh,
in the last several days and read it over,
I'm sure three or four times a each day you yourselves can tell me what are some
of the other issues that come out in First Corinthians?
Right?
So first we have favorite apostles
and we have differences about the resurrection of the body.
Yeah.
Those are two of the issues that Paul has to address.
And First Corinthians,
what are some of the others?
Anybody.
Okay.
Sexual conduct.
And,
uh,
what kinds,
cause there are actually several different issues on sexual conduct and current
in Corinthians.
Yeah,
exactly.
A man is sleeping with his stepmother
and Paul says that's a big no,
no.
Yeah.
Even for the Greeks,
he says even the Greeks don't do that kind of stuff.
So anything what other sexual conduct issues are going on.
How about chapter six in Corinthians?
First Corinthians,
some men,
men in the church are visiting prostitutes.
That's what it means in First Corinthians six when it says,
uh,
where is it?
Do you not know that whoever is United to a prostitute becomes one body with
her?
So some men in the church seem to think,
well,
you know,
what's the big deal?
I'm in Christ,
I'm a Christian.
But you know,
what you do with your body is not that important.
So you know,
every guy's got needs.
So some of these Christian men are visiting prostitutes.
So Paul has to address that issue.
Any other issues of sexuality that Paul has to address in First Corinthians,
there's one more major one.
Pardon?
Virginity.
He does bring it up,
but that's not as big an issue for them as simply the idea of should you get
married.
Remember in First Corinthians seven one they,
they seem to have ask him,
uh,
may,
this is actually putting quotation marks in some of your body bibles.
It is good for a man not to touch a woman.
So,
and now in scholars debate,
is that Paul view or is that something,
a quotation of a slogan of theirs that he's quoting back to them?
So there's a debate about that among some scholars,
but at least some people in court have written him asking particularly about
should we have sex at all or should we be totally aesthetic that is avoid sex
and be a totally continent.
So sex and asceticism
which leads to,
um,
also issues of marriage and divorce.
Okay.
So what other issues are going on?
What about first,
Chris?
The part,
part first part of First Corinthians six,
when any of you has a grievance against one another,
do you dare to take it to court before the unrighteous instead of taking it
before the saints?
So some people,
none of that.
Notice this is the part in the,
in First Corinthians,
that's before Paul mentions the letter.
So this seems to be part of an information he's gotten maybe from Chloe's people
that some people in the Corinthian church are taking other members of the church
to court and suing them.
So court cases.
Here's one issue,
uh,
right after that,
it's the one about the prostitutes,
the marriage and divorce in chapter seven and then eight chapters eight through
11 are all about one big complex issue and that is food offered to idols.
Now,
why is that a problem?
Well,
in the ancient world,
most of the time,
I'll talk about this a little bit further.
Most of the time meat was expensive and if you were not rich,
it was hard to come by.
And so the one place where most people need to well actually had any chance to
eat meat wasn't a sacrificial festival.
What what happened in,
in Greek sacrifices is that somebody rich or the city would pay for a bunch of
cattle or are different kinds of animals to all be slaughtered.
The blood would be poured out and part of this,
the animals would be put on an altar and burn for the gods.
But all the rest of the meat within me passed out and and different people who
went to the festival,
we did it.
So you'd go with your buds and you'll get a big hunk of meat from the sacrifice.
Then you'd go off and barbecue it and have,
you know,
your own barbecue as part of the sacrificial festival.
So most most are you taking back to your family store.
Some of it,
you know,
boil from Hobbit,
that sort of thing.
So the main place that most people can answer the world ate meat,
was connected to some kind of sacrifice to some kind of God.
Now of course,
this is part of the sacrificial cult you're eating.
You're sharing a table with that God,
by eating that sacrificed material,
you're,
it's like you're sitting down to dinner with Zeus when you do this,
right?
So if you're a Jew in the ancient world,
this is causes problems because it means you're,
you don't believe in these gods.
You're supposed to avoid these gods.
You're supposed to avoid idolatry,
but if you eat that meat,
you're still seen by many Jews as participating in that cult with that God.
And also some people believed.
Some of the people thought that was kind of superstitious,
that if you ate that stuff,
then whatever the power that lie behind that God could get into your body by
means of the food.
You can imagine how this happened.
A lot of Jews believed that.
They didn't believe that the idols were just nothing but stone or rock or wood
or metal.
They believed there was something there that was causing that thing to have
power because they looked around,
they said this person claimed to be healed by Asclepius.
Well,
I can see he's now healed,
so who healed him?
I don't believe that the sleepiest is actually a god,
but I believe Asclepius is a demon.
So a lot of Jews would go around and Christians then later saying that the
powers that lie behind the gods of other nations are not really gods,
but they may be demons and if you participate in an eating,
their meat,
that demon could get in your body.
So food offered to idols became a big problem and the early church should you
eat it is so would it hurt you?
It didn't mean you were participating in sacrifice there in chapter 11
I have to change over here another
women praying without veiling their heads.
Okay?
Paul has to address that.
Notice he doesn't say that women can't pray in church,
but he says if they are going to pray in church things,
you put a veil over their heads,
that cause of the angels,
whatever that means.
Then a lot of us who've written a lot on that and I have my own theories and
which most of my friends don't like.
In chapter 11,
later he gets into a big conversation about what they're supposed to do in the
Lord's supper,
when they come together to eat the Lord's supper.
And it's not turning out the way supposed to be.
So that's another issue.
The Lord's supper.
Okay.
Uh,
in chapters 12 through 14,
nobody raised this issue.
Chapters 12 through 14.
What's the big issue that Paul has to address there?
Speaking with tongues.
So the technical term for that is often Glossolalia,
which comes from the Greek word for tons.
So speaking in tongues,
some people in the church or speaking in tongues,
speaking in tongues of course refers to speaking some kind of unknown,
esoteric language that you'd only know by Marac by miracle.
It's a special gift.
It's not an language you learn.
There's a debate among people about when people talk about speaking in tongues,
are they talking about speaking some other human language,
which is known but just not known but not learned by you.
That's what it sounds like.
An axe and axe,
the tongues of fire come down upon the apostles,
you know,
and,
and they all start speaking these strange languages.
And it says everybody who was there visiting from around the world could
understand the apostle speaking in their own language.
So the writer of acts seems to think that speaking in tongues in the early
church refers to this speaking other known human languages are their scholars
think that at different,
at other times it referred to just speaking some kind of unknown language that
would sound to anybody like jibberish.
And that's often how it happens nowadays.
If you go to a church or they're speaking in tongues,
they're not speaking another discernible human language,
they're speaking something else.
And so Paul calls at one point the language of angels.
So sometimes some of these early Christians seem to think that when they spoke
in tongues,
they were speaking the angelic language and they were learning it miraculously.
So speaking in tongues though is an issue in Paul addresses that in those
chapters in 12 to 14 and then as we said,
the last major issue is the resurrection of the body.
Now what holds these different issues together?
What,
what makes all,
are these just a random sort of things that are caught?
The splitting the church,
is it just because some people like speaking in tongues and others don't,
uh,
some people are doing it and others don't.
Is it just because,
um,
uh,
you know,
the court cases,
uh,
is just an isolated incident here or there.
Um,
is the,
is the issue of food offered to idols and their debate about that is that it all
connected to their disagreements about the resurrection of the body and are
those connected their disagreements route sexual conduct?
Because obviously it's their,
they're disagreeing about,
this is why Paul is getting different reports from people.
He's getting some reports from close people and then some others write a letter
and whoever wrote the letters,
probably not the same people that are giving him the oral reports.
So Paul's getting information from different factions in this church.
So the big question is do all of these issues just represent totally different
disparate arguments or is there some bigger reason that these are a debate?
And is there some sort of major divide along which people are lining up?
And so you get a really wonderful,
brilliant book written by a famous New testament scholar Wa
called the Corinthian body and what I tried to do in that book was precisely to
take all of these different issues and show how they could line up on one or two
sides of what was a social status issue.
I argued that not,
it wouldn't be totally neatly,
but what I try,
I tend to try to say is that in a bunch of these different issues,
if you are,
if you had more money,
if you had more access to power,
if you had a better education,
likely you would end up on one side of these issues.
If you didn't have money,
you didn't have power and you didn't have education,
you were more likely to line up on the other side of these issues.
So I argued that the Corinthian church,
which remember was in different house churches and it may have been that one
house church tended to be on one side and another house church tend to be on
another.
We don't know that,
but we know that there were different house churches being represented here in
the church in corn.
So when we talk about the church in Corinth,
we're not just talking about one house church,
we're talking about the collection of them and apparently they may have gone and
gotten together sometimes for a special sort of festival for the Lord Separate
Times,
but they apparently would have been meeting in other people's houses at other
kinds of times.
So let's look at how this would work.
I first the whole Lord's supper issue,
and here is something that I didn't write about,
uh,
on my own.
This was by a famous scholar named Garrett Tyson,
a German scholar.
He published a series of articles in the seventies and eighties in which he made
this argument.
He pointed out,
just like I've already have that meet.
The availability of meat in the ancient world was very much linked to
sacrificial cult.
The argument I just gave you even when even if you weren't going to participate
in the sacrifice itself,
chances are if you went to a butcher shop and wanted to buy meat and it would be
expensive if it was meat at all,
if you,
the chances are that butcher had gotten that meat from some kind of sacrificial,
uh,
activity because the priests sometimes would own them and eat meat.
Sometimes in order to make money for themselves,
they would sell meat to butcher shops.
So it would be almost impossible.
It'd be very difficult unless you yourself were wealthy and you could raise your
own meat,
have it slaughtered your way and consume it yourself and know that it wasn't
connected to the sacrifices at all.
But if you weren't wealthy and couldn't raise your own meat like that and you
just depended upon festivals or the butcher shop,
it would be very difficult to avoid meat that had not been sacrificed to idols.
So what he are that is what you already about,
that he also pointed out that the Lord's supper,
when we look at the Lord's supper,
notice what is happening.
This is in First Corinthians.
Uh,
you find exactly which part of it is,
it's an old chapter 11,
but it's toward the end of chapter 11
yeah,
start reading it.
Chapter 11 verse 17 and the following instructions,
I do not commend you because when you come together it is not for the better,
but for the worst for to begin with.
When you come together as a church,
I hear that there are divisions among you and to some extent I believe it
indeed,
they're happy factions among you for only.
So will it become clear who among you are genuine?
I think he's being ironic there,
but it could be a debate when you come together.
It is not really to eat the Lord's supper for when the time comes to each.
Each of you goes ahead with your own supper.
One goes hungry and another goes drunk.
What do you not have homes to eat and drinking or do you are you show contempt
for the Church of God and humiliate those who have nothing?
What's going on here?
Apparently,
remember I said the early Christian Eucharist Service,
the Lord supper wasn't simply a little bit of wafer and a little bit of wine.
It's a meal of which part of it would be then the saying that the consecration
things like repeating what Paul says,
Jesus had said,
this is my body.
Do this in remembrance of me.
This is my blood.
Do this in my memory.
That might be part of it,
but it's clearly part of a wider meal and it looks like it was something like a
potluck.
Either the rich,
the richer members of the church,
and I don't mean to imply that they're really,
really rich.
We don't think any of these members of Paul's churches were actually members of
the top elite of the Roman Empire.
They weren't senators.
They weren't even a questions,
but they they,
some of them clearly had their own homes,
so that clearly had slaves.
Some of them clearly had some kind of access to financial power.
If they show up at the dinner first,
chances are they've either paid for it themselves.
Because in the ancient world it was typical for people who are wealthier to
supply something for the community.
The wealthy people provided the sacrifices for town sacrifices.
If the town didn't buy it themselves,
but usually the town didn't by themselves.
Usually what the town did was expected wealthy people in the,
in the town to pay for big a civic festivities and sacrifices.
So that's what happened.
Usually the wealthier people would provide the stuff for the festival,
this upper by paying for it or they might have brought it themselves.
So imagine what you have is a potluck like this.
If you're a fairly well off,
you can show up at say five o'clock I'm going to show up at five o'clock in my
buds.
We're going to have a little drink before dinner,
brought an extra bottle of wine and then you know the other people will show up
when they can when they get off work.
Well when you get off work,
if you're a laboring person or a slave in the ancient world,
and slaves did work at regular jobs or they would follow at workday,
you got off work at sundown.
So if you're a working person or especially a slave,
you can't go to the church service until the sun is down.
By that time,
apparently some of the better off people who've already been there,
and Paul seems to say they're already drinking and eating and having a good time
before the rest of the people even show up.
So what he says is he talks about people who have nothing and he says,
don't you have homes to eat and drinking?
Well,
other,
a lot of people in the church would have said,
no,
we don't have homes rapport.
The poor lived kind of anywhere they could.
So Paul is addressing two different kinds of people in this very chapter.
Some of them have,
in fact,
he calls him the haves and the have nots.
That's the Greek he uses so that the Lord's supper is,
is splitting the church along this social status line and Paul Solution.
Paul even says,
if you take the Lord's supper without discerning the body,
and what I think he's talking about is discerning the body of Christ,
that is the other people there.
And discuss.
Discerning the body of your neighbor.
If you don't pay attention to the needs of the other bodies,
they're there and you take the Lord's supper,
it will turn into poison and it will kill you.
And he says,
that's why some of you are getting sick.
Paul believes that some of the Corinthians,
because they're not taking the Lord's supper with the proper ethical concerns
for their neighbors,
the other church members are actually getting sick off the Lord's supper rather
than helping them.
So what's his Paul Solution?
Wait,
if you're that hungry,
eat at home before you get there so you can wait on the other people to come who
have to come later.
So Paul solution is to alter the behavior of the higher status members of the
church to accommodate the needs of the lower status members of the church.
And if you see what's going on here,
you can see that Paul does this over and over again with these different
activities.
I can't go into much detail.
Go out and buy the book,
the Corinthian Body.
You can get it on amazon.com and you can read all about it.
But on each of these things,
I tried to argue there that food offered to idols.
What does Paul Solution?
Well,
he says it won't actually,
you don't even have to worry about it,
but those of you who think it's okay to eat food offered to idols should give it
up if it's going to cause people who think it's wrong to do it,
to do it anyway because that might hurt their conscience.
In other words,
and it's also clear that the people who would've thought this whole thing about
worrying about demons getting to you because you eat idol meat,
they,
if they thought that was ridiculous,
chances are they had some kind of exposure to ancient education because ancient
education taught people that that was ridiculous.
Gods don't do that sort of thing.
So the food offered to idols again,
looks like it split the church along these social class lines.
Um,
the resurrection of the body,
I said,
who would have found the resurrection of the body to be a ridiculous idea?
People with more education,
people exposed to a bit more education,
uh,
who would have been taking people to court.
If you are poor in the ancient world,
you didn't take people to court because you would lose Roman law was even
explicit telling judges if you have a rich man in your case and a poor man in
the case,
well of course you'll does that decide in favor of the rich man because he has
less incentive to cheat.
The poor are the ones who haven't sent into the t.
So Roman law was clearly biased toward the wealthy and the people with power.
So if anybody is taking other Christians to court,
it would be people of higher status,
not people with lower status.
And it may have been that people have higher status.
We're taking their lower status Christian brothers to court Paul there and tells
him,
don't go to court if you have a dispute.
Let it be handled within the church itself.
Now notice again,
just like you talked about file Lehman last time,
who would have been the majority in the Corinthian church?
Rich people or poor people,
poor people.
There may have been some people who are better off,
but they had been vastly outnumbered by the poor people.
So by telling the rich people they have to handle their problems within the
whole church.
He's placing the rich in a situation where they're the minority and that
therefore increases the power of those of lower status in each of these cases.
In other words,
I've argued that the whole Corinthian,
the Corinthian church has problems where they are coming to different views
about Christ,
about the body,
about sex,
about women,
and covering their heads when they pray and prophesied and that sort of thing.
They were coming to the different views because they had different exposures to
upper class ideology or lower class ideology.
Two different exposures to levels of education.
Now,
what happened?
Well,
apparently first Corinthians as a letter did some good because we've yet we have
fortunately other materials for most of Paul's letters,
we don't know whether they succeeded or not because we don't have any other
writing.
And we do have second Corinthians,
which is made up of at least two other letters.
Second Corinthians is actually,
uh,
the first part of it is one letter and then chapters 10 through 13.
In Second Corinthians is another letter.
And if you read them side by side,
you can tell because Paul's tone changes radically when he gets to chapter 10 in
Second Corinthians.
So in Second Corinthians,
we have at least two more letters that Paul wrote.
And then Paul mentions infrastructure is another letter he wrote to them.
So we,
there was another letter going back.
Fuck,
we don't have that one probably.
And in Second Corinthians,
Paul mentions a tearful letter,
a letter he sent,
but it was very difficult for him to write.
He cried over it.
Now some of theirs,
is that referred to another letter or does that refer to the way his,
uh,
Second Corinthians 10 through 13,
which was a very angry letter.
We don't know.
There's a debate about that,
but what we can tell is that the basic things about Paul that Paul addresses in
First Corinthians seem to have been settled by the time we get to second
Corinthians.
Although he has other problems.
And the biggest problem is we,
when that section 10 through 13 a second Corinthians,
because here we get Paul having to defend himself.
And this is very telling because Paul says,
well,
you're talking about the super apostles.
Some other people must have come on the scene.
We don't know who they were,
but Paul ironically caused them super apostles.
You talk about the super apostles,
they're perfectly willing to mistreat you.
They treat,
they're arrogant,
they treat you as if they all the power.
Pardon me,
that I was too weak to do that.
I treated you well,
but maybe that's my weakness showing itself.
And somebody said,
well,
you know,
he's very,
he's very strong in his letters,
but you know,
in person he's kind of a wimp.
He's very weak in person.
His speaking style,
well,
this was a social status thing.
If you were a man in the ancient world,
if he was upper class,
upper status,
he was supposed to be able to talk powerfully in public,
and if he couldn't,
he was survival.
So in,
in this,
in Second Corinthians,
Paul is forced to defend himself from charges that he is uneducated,
weak and powerless,
and therefore not much of an apostle.
Now that goes on in Second Corinthians,
eventually what happens,
we don't know what happened.
Did Paul did riding this really scathing letter to them in Second Corinthians 10
through 13 did that settle the issue?
Do they all just say,
okay,
we were wrong.
You're our apostle,
you're the big daddy,
everything's fine.
We don't know.
We do have a reference in second Clement,
which is a letter written in roam around the end of the first century,
beginning of the second century in which an author talks about the Corinthians
as being an ancient and great church.
So at least by the next generation,
the church in Corinth is strong and powerful and respected.
So eventually Paul's work in Corinth succeeded.
But what we see by looking at first Corinthians and second Corinthians all
together is the struggles it took for Paul to get that church from this,
what I call an adolescent phase where they're arguing about everything.
They're really confused about what they think about basic doctrinal or life
issues,
and then to finally settled down into some kind of coherence.
So that's what makes these letters really fascinating for us is that they give
us a little snapshots of one church that Paul founded at at least three
different stages of its development.
Those three stages being represented by what we can read from first Corinthians,
which kind of gives us one snapshot of this problem they're having.
What we can read from Second Corinthians,
the first nine chapters,
which sounds like they've made up and things are okay and what we can read by
Second Corinthians 10 through 13 which we don't know where that was written
after the first part of Second Corinthians or before it.
We can't.
It's difficult to place these things,
but it shows Paul and a very defensive posture with regard to this church.
So we get a very good idea of how churches struggled to actually start becoming
what we are seeing will become Christianity.
They've got a long way to go yet.
Any questions or comments?
I've covered a lot of area today.
You can go back and read it,
and I haven't even talked about Philippians because I wanted to make sure that
you understood what was going on in scholarly opinion about the Corinthian
epistles.
Any questions,
comments,
outburst?
Okay,
I will see you on Wednesday.